Це один з київських територіальних центрів комплектування, тобто військкоматів.
Тут уже немає таких великих черг, як у перші тижні після 24 лютого.
Тоді пішли воювати і резервісти, і люди без досвіду.
Нині військкомати мають час більш прискіпливо відбирати, хто піде служити,
каже начальник Київського міського центру комплектування.
У нас є така можливість проводити більш детальний медичний огляд військовозобов'язаних,
уже є певна можливість у нас вибирати за станом здоров'я - хто піде в першу чергу, хто піде в іншу чергу.
Більш детально вивчається вже - на це є час - сімейний стан військовозобов'язаних, моральний стан,
морально-ділові якості, в деяких моментах ми вже застосовуємо заходи професійно-психологічного відбору.
При цьому і у військкоматах, і в командуванні ЗСУ наголошують, що так звані "хвилі" мобілізації в Україні умовні.
Нині триває загальна мобілізація. Це означає, що отримати повістку може будь-хто.
Але в пріоритеті - люди з бойовим досвідом.
І все ж, останнім часом можна спостерігати і таке:
Тут все написано, розписано, вказана дата, коли прибути, о котрій прибути, ваше ім'я.
У Києві поліція і військові комісари провели рейди нічними клубами під час комендантської години.
Порушникам закону роздали більше двох сотень повісток.
Офіцер ЗСУ Андрій Ткачук категорично проти роздачі повісток людям на дозвіллі.
Хлопець працював піарником, але 24 лютого добровільно пішов до війська.
На думку військовослужбовця, який саме у звільненні, покарання повістками порушників принижує честь військових.
У моєму оточенні переважна більшість не розуміє ось цих процесів, коли повістку використовують як метод покарання.
Окей, треба покарати людей - покарайте їх правильно, покарайте їх згідно закону, штрафи,
придумайте публічні роботи, відправте людину порозбирати завали на Чернігівщині чи в інших містах.
Людина порушує комендантську годину - заарештуйте її.
Є суд, є багато речей. Але водночас поважайте сьогодні і військових, які віддали життя військовій службі,
які з мотивацією прийшли 24 лютого і служать.
Водночас начальник Київського міського центру комплектування певен,
що поки в державі триває війна, нагадування про це не буде зайвим.
Скажімо так: якщо людина порушує комендантську годину, одразу постає питання -
якщо ти маєш час під час комендантської години, порушуючи вимоги законодавства,
відпочивати, хоча це не погано, відпочивати в якомусь закладі,
то чому ти не виконуєш свій військовий і громадянський обов'язок із захисту батьківщини?
У різних містах України представники військкоматів також дедалі частіше зупиняють людей просто на вулиці.
Євгеній Романчук з Житомирщини запевняє, що із військкомами на вулиці стикався тричі.
Щоразу йому намагалися вручити повістку.
Зламалася машина. І мені довелося йти на зупинку до автобуса, щоб поїхати додому.
Метрів 20 до зупинки не доходячи, мене зупинили військовий комісаріат і сказали:
"Добрий день, ви стоїте на обліку?". Я сказав, що ні. Мені сказали: "Тримайте, вам повістка".
Потім чоловіка нібито зупиняли ще двічі: на іншій зупинці транспорту й на заправці.
Утім, на той час він уже мав висновок лікарів:
до служби Євгеній тимчасово непридатний, адже хворіє на бронхіальну астму.
Сам чоловік каже, що за потреби готовий іти в армію. Але мобілізації "на зупинках" дивується.
Повістку вручили - це не дуже то і страшно.
За повісткою тебе не заберуть одразу, тебе посилають на медичний огляд.
Мене здивувало, що до мене вже три рази підходили.
Я уже, буває, на базарі, де їх бачу, я уже спеціально призупиняюся,
щоб до мене підійшли і запропонували цю повістку і вручили. Це взагалі нонсенс якийсь.
До адвоката Станіслава Бориса протягом останніх кількох тижнів почастішали звернення від чоловіків,
які хочуть проконсультуватися, чи законно їм вручили повістки.
Багато хто цей документ так само отримав на вулиці.
Дійсно в законодавстві не зазначено конкретного місця. Тобто вони можуть бути вручені будь-де.
Інший момент - це те, що їх дійсно виписують "на коліні".
Якщо вичитати дуже багато комплексно норм з різних правових актів і звести в одну,
то можна сказати, що правильним би було чисто юридично,
щоб дійсно була виписана повістка в комплектувальному центрі, у військкоматі,
на конкретну людину і безпосередньо їй вручена.
Ну, фактично сказати, що це найгрубіше порушення, чи це робить сповіщення незаконним, не доводиться.
Водночас юрист наголошує, що вручати повістки повинні співробітники військкоматів,
органів місцевого самоврядування, керівники підприємств і установ.
Тоді як поліція чи представники тероборони самі цього робити не можуть.
Також адвокат відзначає, що повістка має бути належно оформлена.
Мають бути вказані особисті дані отримувача, вид повістки, коли й куди треба з'явитися,
підпис і печатка керівника центру комплектування.
Юрій Ерметов, викладач математики з Хмельницького, поштою отримав документ, у якому такої інформації не було.
У повістці не зовсім було зрозуміло, що це таке, бо я знаю, що є декілька форм, навіщо я мав туди з’явитися.
Або уточнити облікові дані, або пройти медкомісію, або власне вже піти у військо.
А в повістці цього не було зазначено, і дата не була зазначена.
Тобто моє прізвище і що треба з’явитися. А навіщо, куди, в який день - нічого цього не було.
Юрій каже, що хоч і має групу за інвалідністю, добровільно звертався до центру комплектування 24 лютого,
але тоді йому відмовили. Після вручення повістки ще раз підтвердили непридатність.
Хоча другий похід до військкомату змусив чоловіка понервувати.
Мене викликали, прямо не сказали, для чого.
І я собі все це прокрутив, врешті-решт навіть собі десь подумав, що навряд чи так буде,
але готуєшся до всього, розумієш - так, таке може бути, а раптом доведеться піти.
Врешті-решт як громадянину, то це нормально.
Юристи відзначають, що теоретично повістка, яку отримав Юрій - незаконна.
Її можна було б оскаржити в суді, якби чоловік не пішов до військкомату і його намагалися притягти до відповідальності.
Йдеться, зокрема, про штраф до 3400 гривень за неявку для проходження лікарської комісії.
Якщо ж військовозобов'язаного визнали придатним, а він ухиляється від служби,
це вже кримінальна відповідальність - від трьох до п'яти років позбавлення волі.
Сама суть, що вона вручена неуповноваженою особою, можливо, містить не всі необхідні реквізити -
аргументи з цього приводу можна надавати в суді в разі притягнення до адміністративної відповідальності,
або правоохоронним органам чи в суді в разі притягнення до кримінальної відповідальності.
Ми нікого не закликаємо ухилятися чи якимось іншим чином уникати військової служби,
але ми за те, щоб все відбувалося чітко з вимогами законодавства.
Для мобілізації є і винятки. Їй не підлягають, наприклад, особи, які виховують трьох і більше дітей
або опікуються дитиною з інвалідністю чи тяжкою хворобою.
Також військовозобов'язаний може бути заброньований за підприємством чи установою,
якщо у них є мобілізаційні завдання. Наприклад, якщо це фабрика, яка шиє взуття для армії.
На думку військового Андрія Ткачука, військова служба - не для всіх,
але під час війни кожен має знайти для себе межу між війною і мирним життям.
Якщо ти крутий волонтер і ти забезпечуєш ось це і ось це, то в принципі,
якщо ти не хочеш служити, то ти не будеш служити.
Бо ти приносиш от стільки, а в армії ти будеш корисний от на стільки.
У нас сьогодні не воює там, як хтось казав, схід чи не схід. У нас сьогодні воює ціла держава.
І треба сьогодні знайти своє застосування.
Ще раз повторюся - не забути про своє особисте життя, про власне життя.
Якщо в цивільному житті ви відпочиваєте, насолоджуйтеся цим. Для цього ведеться війна.
Наразі мобілізація в Україні офіційно продовжена до 23 серпня.
Але в Міноборони наголошують, що вона триватиме доти, поки треба буде комплектувати підрозділи,
які чинять спротив окупантам.